Super Bowl tradition with a new twist just
before kickoff tomorrow and right after the
national anthem fans at State Farm stadium in
Arizona will be treated to a very special Navy
flyover four Jets flown by seven women will join
a list of Super Bowl first while commemorating 50
years since women were allowed to be Navy Pilots
but before they make their televised flyby these
Pilots got another test flying with our own Chris
Van Cleave who joins us from State Farm Stadium
lucky guy with a behind the scenes look Chris good
morning good morning arguably their biggest test
was putting up with me in the back seat there but
these are highly trained highly skilled Pilots
that have been you know honing these Aviation
skills for years they've flown combat missions
this will probably be their highest profile
Mission ever they even put up with the occasional
civilian in the back seat but they're also
furthering a legacy of women on the flight deck
taking off from Luke Air Force Base Lieutenant
Peggy Dente is getting ready for what will be
the highest profile mission of her Navy career
buzzing State Farm Stadium right after the
national anthem have you done a flyover before I
have not no it's my first one small stage for a
first flyover yeah no pressure nervous you know
I think it'd be crazy if you weren't a little
bit nervous but a little bit of nerves keeps you
honest keeps you humble keeps you focused on the
mission Sunday's four fighter flyover will have
an all-woman team of seven as the Navy celebrates
50 years of female Pilots it wasn't until 1973
when eight women were first allowed to enter
flight school six earned their wings about a year
after graduating Rosemary Mariner became the first
woman assigned to Pilot a Navy fighter women now
make up about 15 percent of Naval aviators it is
not lost on me how special it is that I get
to do what I'm doing today because they did
it first the significance of this Super Bowl first
wasn't lost some of the NFL's greats several Hall
of Famers visited the pilots and their support
Crews Thursday to thank them for their service
it's definitely a huge honor to be asked to
do this and to celebrate those women that have
paved this way for all of us Lieutenant's Ariel
Ash and Sheree Moreno will be leading the diamond
formation I don't think we have any question about
the execution of it I think it's going to go just
a plan because you have to be there at down to the
second that's correct we're used to the mission
maybe not so much used to the publicity Pilots
have had a couple weeks to prepare including
this Friday practice flight but first lieutenant
Dente is showing us what her ea-18 Growler can do
that which meant pulling a 6G turn that's six
times the force of gravity pressing down upon us
and apparently it's not a True Flight
if you don't go upside down how did I do
you did really well Chris I didn't throw up
I didn't pass out no neither of those things
I think you did great Dante fell in love with
Aviation as a kid learning to fly with her dad
the inspiration to join the Navy came from her
grandfather who flew helicopters in Vietnam now
she and the rest of these Pilots get a chance to
inspire a new generation of aviators I think it's
a message not just to young girls but to young
people that they can do whatever they set their
mind to and if they want to be a Jet Pilot
that is well within the possibility for them
and obviously these flyovers don't just happen
there's been a ton of coordination with the FAA
the NFL the TV production to make sure this
all happens right at the right moment they're
confident they will execute this Mission I have to
tell you guys one thing that I was struck by Peggy
and her electronic warfare officer the person
who sits in the back seat where I was sitting
they've known each other since college and I have
to say they are fellow USC Trojan Alum so fight on
about that I was trying to figure out Chris how
you were going to get that in there because I saw
you tweet that earlier in the week gotta love it
I'm obligated I was obligated to do it fight on
he followed the keys don't throw up don't pass out
nice job as you well know there you go Dana yeah
all three of us welcome to the club it knows Jesus
great story and it's always fun to watch those